well check it out we're looking at a  live webcam  for lee canyon while winter's not here  yet officially the winter season begins  today lifts are running at 9am  this morning so they're up there  grooming the mountain right now the  resort says it expects all chair lifts  to be open and running today  and wow you can see they've got snow  they've been making snow  but you can also see there are some  exposed rocks and a few  little dry patches there so please  everybody be safe and do know that you  have to have parking reservations  masks are required and you have to have  reservations to get up there to  ski or snowboard so please don't go up  there unprepared  or you'll be disappointed but it's nice  to see